[Musique]
la première visite de Geneviève Darius
sec ministre délégué chargé des
personnes handicapées se déroulissent
jeudi 15 décembre au foyer d'accueil
médicalisé à la maison d'accueil
spécialisée de la fondation perfavron à
Saint-Benoît
accompagné par Cyril Melchior président
du Département cette première séquence
ministérielle c'est clôturée par une
table ronde autour du dispositif de la
plateforme d'accompagnement au logement
et d'insertion
c'est que c'est un territoire innovant
qui a mis en place des des dispositifs
de
soutien d'abord
dispositif qui va recueillir la parole
des personnes en situation de handicap
dans les établissements qui en fait
découvrent que certains veulent être
autonomes dans des logements et qui
construisent tout cette accès à
l'autonomie dans un logement
inclusif ou en tout cas un logement
autonome
c'est assez formidable et donc je crois
que ça fait partie des dispositifs
d'avenir pour faire en sorte ce qui est
important c'est le toit pour tout le
monde et faire en sorte que les
personnes en situation de handicap
puisse avoir un logement ont aux
autonomie si elle le souhaite
voilà ce que j'ai entendu ce matin était
très intéressant et nous pourrons avec
monsieur le Président du Conseil
départemental construire des solutions
pour le futur
schéma de développement accéléré que
nous allons mettre en oeuvre ici sur
l'île de la Réunion
le président suit accompagné la ministre
à la MDPH de Saint-Denis Maison
départementale pour les personnes
handicapées un lieu d'accueil
d'information essentiel qui accompagne
les conseils les personnes en situation
de handicap ainsi que leur famille
la dernière séquence de cette visite
ministérielle s'est déroulée dans
l'hémicycle du Palais de la source ce
vendredi 16 décembre le protocole
d'accord entre l'État et le département
était signé il prévoit de renforcer
l'engagement commun au profit du
territoire et des Réunionnais dans
plusieurs domaines
vous savez que deux joueurs de visite
comme madame la ministre nous a
accordé ce sont deux joueurs importants
et qui se terminent par la signature de
ce protocole qui fixe en fait plusieurs
axes mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que nous avons des retards ici à la
réunion d'accueil en terme de formation
des personnels aussi accueillants et le
retard accumulés se conjugue malgré tout
d'une grosse volonté du territoire
beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup de
partenaires qui se mobilisent et bien
puisqu'il y a cette mobilisation des
partenaires j'ai dit à madame la
ministre il faut nous accompagner en
termes de moyens pour rattraper ses
retards et j'ai bien entendu ce soir que
la réunion sera accompagnée à hauteur de
2 millions d'euros
et elle m'a rassuré cette un début c'est
le premier pas de la construction d'un
projet
département état à travers la RS pour
renforcer les soutiens d'accueil quoi
faire en sorte que la réunion soit plus
inclusive que l'accueil notamment des
adultes porteurs de handicap va se phase
dans les meilleures conditions sur notre
territoire
un tour d'horizon complet pour cette
visite ministérielle qui montre la
nécessité de conforter la stratégie
départementale et les politiques
publiques en matière d'infusion du
handicap
[Musique]